**Susan Daniels***: got it Thank you appreciate the chat um so welcome back everybody, this is session one part three in the morning.
**Susan Daniels***: And we're going to cover negotiate project agreements and then.
**Susan Daniels***: we're going to look at.
**Susan Daniels***: What was the other one i'm sorry all and how to how to empower TEAM members and stakeholders will break out 130 Eastern time for one hour and will rejoin at 230 Eastern time.
**Susan Daniels***: I do want to take a moment to give a shout out to our mentoring team that is been answering questions all morning.
**Susan Daniels***: They have done over 320 questions in the Q amp a and you know they've been answering them in the chat as well, I do want to re emphasize that the Q amp a is for technical questions.
**Susan Daniels***: And you know, regarding your your equipment your your arm access to your.
**Susan Daniels***: curriculum material it's really you know very specific questions and are not addressing the the conversation that we're having a hand are the curriculum that's being covered.
**Susan Daniels***: Now, if you miss a point you got distracted on during a lecture and you would just want a point of clarification on the topic that was just covered, you can also ask that either in the chatter in the Q amp a.
**Susan Daniels***: chances are your peers can answer your year and clarify that question in the chat for you and we can keep moving but do save your technical questions.
**Susan Daniels***: For me, or your resource material questions for the Q amp a unless just keep the chat for the conversation about the class.
**Susan Daniels***: So we're about to head into negotiate project agreements.
**Susan Daniels***: we've talked a lot that negotiating is what we do almost all day and we saw the chat list of variety of things that we negotiate whether it's the resources, the priorities, the objectives the schedules, you know managing expectations were negotiating all the time.
**Susan Daniels***: And we also acknowledge that conflict arises, and we need to be prepared to deal with it and how we're going to deal with it and that goes conflict management goes into our team charter how we're going to handle conflict.
**Susan Daniels***: And now we're going to talk about negotiate project agreements, which is something that i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: Is the lead role, one of the major accountabilities of the project manager, this is part of your integration, how you pull it all together you've got the vision.
**Susan Daniels***: Of what the end States going to be you have defined it in your charter you've made you've got the expectations of your senior leadership.
**Susan Daniels***: And now you're setting forth to try to get the agreements in place between all of the working bodies in your organization and sometimes outside your organization to get the work pulled together and in organized to get her done.
**Susan Daniels***: So there are different kinds of organizational agreements there's service level agreements as in setting expectations for production productivity of this particular division of the company.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm in my hand to do with response times on the phone lines to support your product that's going to be launched on it might be negotiating.
**Susan Daniels***: service level agreements and how much resources are the staff members are going to give me and how frequently I can have them and for how long I can have them, you know this is service level agreements.
**Susan Daniels***: you're also going to be negotiating performance reports, what is the template look like How often is it going to be provided, what elements are going to be included who's responsible for it right.
**Susan Daniels***: This isn't the negotiating on agreement your resource calendars your resource calendars are very much a part of your agreement, which is.
**Susan Daniels***: What resources, particularly equipment or access to rooms and testing environments and heavy equipment, all of this has to be negotiated and it's put into on your resource calendar what days when right and who can have it, and under what conditions and what what cost.
**Susan Daniels***: Another interesting Liam is often negotiated arm is negotiating with your team, particularly an agile when they're about to do.
**Susan Daniels***: A big product release into the real environment taking it out of the testing environment and making it go live.
**Susan Daniels***: On they're basically saying we have glow live blackout dates, it means we're not accepting any changes or any new work during this time sort of puts a nice.
**Susan Daniels***: guard rail around your core team, so that they get to focus on what they need to focus on and all other communications not relative to the go live or deferred and that's articulated in a service agreement.
**Susan Daniels***: So one of the things that you will see as an enabler are, of course, the negotiation skills and I saw someone in the chat.
**Susan Daniels***: Put an excellent link out to a resource on how to hone your negotiation skills and, if you want to put that back out again that would be valuable, but knowing how to negotiate is foundational to success.
**Susan Daniels***: We weren't doing our negotiation of our project agreements you've got to get the right people in the room to help you do it.
**Susan Daniels***: You need the expert in it to make sure that what you're asking for is articulated in a way that.
**Susan Daniels***: meets expectations on both sides and you may not be the best person okay to negotiate this, you may not know the shop talk.
**Susan Daniels***: You might not be an expert in this field right as project managers, we are jack of many trades and a master of none, or we.
**Susan Daniels***: Are knowledge goes a mile wide and maybe only an inch thick in some areas, so we often bring in experts to help us negotiate on exactly what's required in the language or acronyms that is that the other party will understand.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i'm just checking the chat.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i'm sorry that you guys are bouncing off over there um it may be just your wi fi is disruptive in that area and we'll talk about the value of lessons learned because we get later into today.
**Susan Daniels***: So we're trying to set our agreements for our project and, of course, the first thing we need to know is defining.
**Susan Daniels***: Success right you start with the end in mind, according to Stephen covey and you define success, and then you back into what does it take to get there.
**Susan Daniels***: So traditional says that we're going to identify each deliverable.
**Susan Daniels***: And what is the definition of success, the objective you know what's an acceptable criteria okay to say yes, that is well done, that is acceptable Okay, so you start there.
**Susan Daniels***: That is your beginning point of negotiation and oftentimes, that is when the other party will tell you whether they can do that, or they start immediately negotiating the objective so that's your starting point, but once you've agreed on what is the acceptance criteria and the objective.
**Susan Daniels***: Then you start backing into our resources and timelines and risk might be associated.
**Susan Daniels***: and agile you come at it a little bit differently okay.
**Susan Daniels***: When you are doing these agreements, it is.
**Susan Daniels***: On a shorter to horizon term you're not negotiating the entire deliverable thought the entire product build and design, because you might have many, many features that you want to add to it.
**Susan Daniels***: you're basically starting to negotiate what is considered a minimally viable product or you may be negotiating what is a minimal business increment that would be acceptable.
**Susan Daniels***: we're on those terms to come, but please know we have a different approach and we have a different language when we're talking an agile.
**Susan Daniels***: What is the objectives and definition of acceptance criteria for the final products okay or process, the other one is just a short term i'm on a very short term horizon line.
**Susan Daniels***: We may also need to negotiate the definition of done okay definition of done is a key term that you're going to need to know for understanding them agile methodology.
**Susan Daniels***: And 50% of the tmp exam is on agile methodology, a lot of the focus we're going to cover for the next couple of days is primarily traditional plan based project management plan your work, work, your plan control for variances.
**Susan Daniels***: An agile it's a different approach Lamont more adaptive a lot more flexible, a lot more job.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so definition of done is literally like a checklist of what each little product or each.
**Susan Daniels***: deliverable has to go through before it is released.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i'm sorry my phone on my watch went off and I needed to make sure it wasn't the support team.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so when we talk about negotiating agreements agreements is a very broad umbrella term Okay, there are different kinds of agreement that can be negotiated.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay service level agreements are probably the most common used in private industry that basically are between departments within an organization vpn and directors sit down with you and agree to meet the needs of each other so that your project can be successful.
**Susan Daniels***: But if you're working sometimes outside of your organization other agreements that you may be negotiating.
**Susan Daniels***: Our contracts are memorandums of understanding now memorandums of understanding are a precursor are come before you actually finalize a contract.
**Susan Daniels***: They are that negotiation at the table, where you come to an understanding and before we get all the legal involved and we get the formal.
**Susan Daniels***: Legal legal documents together and everyone signing it officially we create a memorandum or a letter that says we agree to do this in in compensation for that right we we agree and that's.
**Susan Daniels***: put in writing and taken back to legal the organizations, then you're like oh yeah we can we can do that that's we agree with those terms, so the upline agrees to it.
**Susan Daniels***: And then they come back and they start to go the contract.
**Susan Daniels***: You may or may not be involved in the actual legal contract negotiation, but you highly highly likely may be involved in sitting at the table doing memorandums of understanding with various vendors, you need to get your project done.
**Susan Daniels***: Do you need to be a procurement expert, not necessarily, but there are certain procurement concepts that will cover later that you need to know is just basic understanding certain terms certain contract types certain terminology Memorandum of Understanding is one of those.
**Susan Daniels***: Of course, you can have verbal agreements and emails are very effective documentation that you ever reached an agreement with someone.
**Susan Daniels***: When you see these little check marks it's a pretty good idea to slow down and study this lie it where they can list a series of things and you need to understand what is a part of okay.
**Susan Daniels***: This really comes down to negotiating project agreements, so these would all fall under the task of beverage project agreements, I thought I saw a question come through let me check chat for a moment.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, it flew by oh how seriously are verbal agreements taken F at all in project management.
**Susan Daniels***: Honestly, you know verbal agreements are worth the paper they're written on, is an old saying so.
**Susan Daniels***: People can always miss remember you know how things work how the conversation went.
**Susan Daniels***: So as a project manager verbal agreements are good things I mean you might be moving through the company, you might meet them in the elevator break room cafeteria you don't know where you're going to meet them, you have the conversation you agree.
**Susan Daniels***: Before the end of that business day Okay, you need to follow up with hey just a quick note to confirm our understanding we reached our, then the agreement that we reached on at lunch today or in you know site when and where and then bullet out what the agreement is okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Please review revise and return with your comments you know by tomorrow afternoon I but document document document.
**Susan Daniels***: But there's no harm in striking verbal agreements as long as you have the supporting documentation to fall back on.
**Susan Daniels***: yeah follow up as a recap right.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Sometimes, when you have a lot of change orders within a project, the pm, and the contractors will do a verbal agreement before sending over the change documents.
**Susan Daniels***: um yeah I mean you don't want to go through all the effort of developing the change documentation which will then become an addendum to the contract.
**Susan Daniels***: With without having you know clear the path and have verbal agreement in advance, but again, the verbal agreement is not worth anything really it's only the supporting documentation that holds people accountable.
**Susan Daniels***: This has a whole slide dedicated to it and you would think why would they have a whole slide dedicated to one statement when you've seen other slides that are just loaded with text right because it's a key concept.
**Susan Daniels***: You do not go in to a negotiation if you're following PM eyes code of ethics Okay, particularly under fair okay.
**Susan Daniels***: The goal is to reach an agreement to try to create a win, win solution okay we're both parties would want to work with these each other again.
**Susan Daniels***: What they're trying to counter act is this it's a killer deal I made them bleed okay at one hurts so bad okay.
**Susan Daniels***: So you don't want to punish or drive to you know, a killing deal whether they're barely going to come out with any sort of profit or be able to survive the deal, they may, that is not the goal of negotiations if you're a project manager with the PM p.
**Susan Daniels***: Certification brand OK, you are to be fair and honest and trying to create a business relationship that you want to sustain with this organization.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, it is when when is the answer to any question related to negotiation okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Now oftentimes in the negotiation strategy meeting on procurement from your corporation will be there to support you Okay, they are there to protect the project that the company's assets.
**Susan Daniels***: And both sometimes legal might be there at the table, while you're doing your your Memorandum of Understanding.
**Susan Daniels***: But don't feel like you're always doing this alone, you often have resources available and will coach you in sometimes they just want to make sure that you're there to answer any question relative to the actual deliverable they will handle all other questions on your behalf.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay um.
**Susan Daniels***: Oh well, he says, you do this, unless you don't care about the future relationship with said company.
**Susan Daniels***: On you must always care about the future relationship um.
**Susan Daniels***: As a project manager you're going to stay you're going to find a business domain you're probably going to go deep and excel in that business domain, whether it's finance or healthcare.
**Susan Daniels***: Defense department or it, but whatever it is you do there's only so many companies that play in that business still re domain and there's only so many supporting companies.
**Susan Daniels***: For those is a smaller world than you think and you don't want to have the reputation when you walk in their room to negotiate somebody goes oh it's that guy.
**Susan Daniels***: Oh it's her right you want people when they you walk into the room to negotiate they're glad to see you Okay, because you may see them again in a different role, even as your career progresses care about your relationships internally and externally in the company.
**Susan Daniels***: world is smaller than you think you don't get to burn any bridges Okay, because you may have to walk back over them.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, in traditional and important objective clearly designates the projects intended deliverable and how they will be measured and compensated, which is really what I was saying before.
**Susan Daniels***: know your objective your definition of success, what is success acceptance criteria and you negotiate towards that.
**Susan Daniels***: In agile.
**Susan Daniels***: What you're exactly going to deliver is not as.
**Susan Daniels***: is not defined in the beginning okay it's not plan your work, work, your plan control for variances you're just trying to understand what is needed at this juncture of time right.
**Susan Daniels***: And with the the backlog or all the work that still needs to be done gets re prioritize will come back around and we'll figure out what we need to how we need to work together, next time lot more negotiation in.
**Susan Daniels***: agile because you're working with the product owner on a regular cadence So what do you need now and howdy, how do we get that done for you okay on a regular cadence has your review the whole backlog of things that can be done to build this product this product.
**Susan Daniels***: This is a very robust list OK.
**Susan Daniels***: OK.
**Susan Daniels***: I see your question.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i'm being asked is the highlighted difference between the agile and traditional approaches to several of the concepts discussed so far, something that's important for the.
**Susan Daniels***: exam updates yes there's a whole slide putting them in juxtaposition So yes, as part of the exam will they be looking to acknowledge the difference between these two concepts, yes, basically any of these slides that are produced by pmi can be flipped into MP MP exam prep question.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm just asking you to recognize that when you see a checklist that you need to know what it ties to understand what know your guidance is.
**Susan Daniels***: know your vocabulary and we will go much richer and deeper into agile on the fifth day I mean we start with the whole agile and scrum process and we take us through the scrum process but that's here we just want to show where there are clear differences between the two methodologies.
**Susan Daniels***: So, in negotiations, this is just an example of all the different things that we might be negotiating.
**Susan Daniels***: And it's just an essential part of your role.
**Susan Daniels***: So I want performance reports was touched on earlier in that on you really have to figure out what's going to be reported by WHO what what's the what's the.
**Susan Daniels***: goal, or the benchmark that you're going to compare actually to write how frequently is it going to be done, where is it going to be stored right.
**Susan Daniels***: who's got authority to update it, who has access to that folder with the arm the performance report in it, because not everybody gets to see every aspect of the project right maybe the the financials are not everybody's business.
**Susan Daniels***: But one of the concepts that you'll need to know is the difference between data, information and a report okay I performance report.
**Susan Daniels***: data is raw output from a process, I want you to think of an excel spreadsheet or any kind of spreadsheet which is loaded with numbers okay it's just a tire table of numbers, you have data.
**Susan Daniels***: Work performance data is integrating and contextualize okay to create information okay information is when you put it in a chart or graph or you summarize it in a narrative What if you put it in on a an infographic okay that that helps explain it okay any any.
**Susan Daniels***: visual way that is taking data and putting it in information can you use information okay to be able to generate decisions.
**Susan Daniels***: Or to raise issues hey I see the variance here, I see it right.
**Susan Daniels***: Now information just taking the data and putting it into a chart or graph or summarizing it, you have not created a report, I repeat, taking data and putting it into information you've not created a report what you've created is information on which a report can be made.
**Susan Daniels***: Reports always compare actual to goal okay actual to objective, then a good report will explain the reason for the variance a very good report will go further and explain recommendations to control or fix the variance.
**Susan Daniels***: supper report would not only tell me where i'm at compared to where I need to be what's driving my variance and what I should do about it a superior report would also.
**Susan Daniels***: look ahead and notify leadership of any no risks that could cause the performance to go down or to adversely impacted me give you an example hey.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm we are performing on 12% below target, this is driven by turnover in X position hey recommend posting for backfilling as soon as possible.
**Susan Daniels***: point of information we're expecting a resignation in a similar position are in the same position by the end of the month okay amended recommendation post for both positions as soon as possible.
**Susan Daniels***: As a recipient of that Okay, I know what's going on what's wrong and what to do about it and how to proactively respond to problems in the future.
**Susan Daniels***: We negotiate these sort of performance reports, if you design your performance reports such that they not only give you actual event your actual.
**Susan Daniels***: plan, but they also give you recommendations right, you know define the various make recommendations and a space for future looking concerns you will be empowering yourself and your sponsors to navigate and guide this project more effectively.
**Susan Daniels***: So one of the things that you need in developing your on your performance reports is you're going to need the right person to help you develop it right you're going to need experts.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: I just I just saw the chat fly through my apologies okay so.
**Susan Daniels***: don't feel like you need to be the only person to develop these performance reports, much like you might not be the right person to negotiate the service level agreement, you may need some.
**Susan Daniels***: Experts to come in, they can talk that business domain better than you can well, you may also need to call upon experts to help you design and build your performance reports.
**Susan Daniels***: Were back to resource calendars again.
**Susan Daniels***: You may need to check in okay we're back to resource calendars.
**Susan Daniels***: When we were trying to set up.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm sorry give me a SEC Okay, so we were trying to build our team, and we were building our team, we had to estimate what kind of players, we needed right.
**Susan Daniels***: We also need to find out what kind of resources are available and when, and these resource calendars once we had them, who I could have when and for how long right how much do they cost.
**Susan Daniels***: We put this in a resource calendar, while this seems to be very manual until we got very digitized and we have these great tools that are available now to help us we listed many of them on this morning.
**Susan Daniels***: But your digital resource calendar is very much part of your resource management plan Okay, not only the roles and responsibilities of your different players and you're.
**Susan Daniels***: rewarded reward and recognition right, but you also have to make sure that you have your calendar as well, one of the things that get tricky and I do mean tricky about how to do these resource calendars is estimating your project activities really understanding i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: Sorry.
**Susan Daniels***: What we need, and when we need it and for how long, so we have different ways of estimating our resources, give me a moment and I will TEE this up.
When assembling your project team and staffing all of your project activities you'll need to determine what resources are needed.
You can collect information from your existing TEAM members and subject matter, experts and also talk with various departments in your organization to determine the availability of resources.
resource types can include human resources or people and physical resources, which includes materials equipment and supplies.
considerations should include the types of resources needed the quantity of resources required and the required skill sets and project team roles and availability.
Depending on what you find when you're estimating your activity resource needs and comparing it to resource availability, you may need to look at procuring resources from a third party vendor.
**Susan Daniels***: Here is a little resource terminology that you might find helpful over allocated resources are those who are dedicated to too many tasks at once.
**Susan Daniels***: This can happen when the project manager is borrowing TEAM members from other departments and their functional managers need the employees to perform their regular work to.
**Susan Daniels***: It can also happen when we realize that a project needs to be completed earlier than we thought and now TEAM members are working overtime.
**Susan Daniels***: benched resources are not being utilized even though they're available and they may be receiving a salary, this can be wasteful and can become expensive the project manager, is responsible for coordinating the right resources at the right time.
**Susan Daniels***: A resource calendar is a helpful tool for comparing resource needs and resource availability.
**Susan Daniels***: You can determine how team Member vacations holidays conference room and resource ability all stack up to give you the best dates to perform particular activities.
**Susan Daniels***: You can also spot gaps and concerns well in advance, so you can take action.
**Susan Daniels***: keep in mind that resource calendars are more helpful in traditional projects where you create the plan, well in advance.
**Susan Daniels***: It isn't so helpful when you're performing agile project work and the scope and resource needs can be changing and evolving constantly.
**Susan Daniels***: In that case, the best solution is when the project team is cross functional and all resources and equipment are dedicated to the project work that way they're available when needed and project activities can run more smoothly.
bottom up, estimating is a very detailed estimating technique which uses the estimates from work packages and aggregates them or adds them up to come up with an overall estimate of the project resource requirements.
bottom up, estimating can be very time consuming, which means that the estimate itself can become expensive, but this type of estimate is usually very accurate because you've taken the time to examine the project in the finest detail.
The resource breakdown structure, provides a hierarchical diagram of the resources required for a project.
This structure has a number of qualities it's visually simple showing resource information at a glance it breaks resources into categories and resource types.
And it helps you to organize project schedule data and report on resource utilization information in this example we're only considering the human resources for the project, but a resource breakdown structure will also include the other resources, including materials equipment and supplies.
Once you've estimated your resources for your project, you can use this information to estimate the project budget and schedule.
Resources are generally the largest expense on a project and resource estimates can be coordinated with cost estimates.
they'll help you to determine what the project will cost and also what the project can afford they can be used to develop a realistic project schedule.
Depending on what you learn about your resources and the impact they'll have on the budget and schedule, you may need to modify your plans.
To possibly move work from a third party to in house or the other way around, you may also decide to lengthen your schedule or modify your budget so that your cash flows work with the anticipated payrolls and other expenses related to your resources.
**Susan Daniels***: notice that we have a lot of people coming in at the one o'clock and we appear to have.
**Susan Daniels***: two classes trying to join the same same zoom if you are year for the arm the April May, June on North American cohort of the ATP bootcamp, and this is your your day five session.
**Susan Daniels***: There is an alternative link that is being put into the chat please use that link to jump into the zoom meeting we apologize for the confusion, he did sort of jump into something that process this one started at 10 o'clock this morning.
**Susan Daniels***: So i'm will continue to put that link in the chat, but please, please use that to join the the cohort you are looking for.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so I did have someone who wanted me to reiterate the difference between a information and a report.
**Susan Daniels***: Data converted into context where you've put it into a chart a graph on narrative okay you're just you're just basically i'm clarifying actual against plan.
**Susan Daniels***: That data interpreted the actual against plan that's just creating information reports are based on information you incorporate our reference, the information see chart AC see graph be on in your report, it is the report that.
**Susan Daniels***: Basically, tells leadership.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm where we are what's causing it, what we need to do about it, and what might be happening next relative to our performance in this matter, so I hope that was helpful to the student who asked for the reiteration.
**Susan Daniels***: So, yes, we negotiated all of these reports, we would negotiate it on expectations.
**Susan Daniels***: And so now.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm sorry I don't think the audio is choppy I think it's me i'm catching a breath between talking um so we have.
**Susan Daniels***: we've gone through all the effort to build the reports and the reports start to come in.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, part of our role is to analyze the information when we get to the communication section you'll see that I say as a project manager.
**Susan Daniels***: The information comes to you is interpreted by you and is disseminates out through you, you were sort of the central point of contact for almost all communications well, one of the things that we take into consideration when looking at our performance reports are.
**Susan Daniels***: The lessons learned right when we find that the project is not going according to plan.
**Susan Daniels***: And we experiencing risks that manifest those are called issues Okay, sometimes they're the risks are pre identified sometimes they're not.
**Susan Daniels***: But when we have issues that arise, we want to capture those on the issue log and keep our senior leadership informed on what we're working on and its status Okay, when we expect to have it resolved.
**Susan Daniels***: But we also keep something called a lessons learned Okay, and this really is.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, I have learned that I need to communicate with this organization, you know the contact in this organization is more robust than having use this particular contact, or that the distribution list for this report should include these parties that I didn't do originally right.
**Susan Daniels***: So that if you come back and do the project again right.
**Susan Daniels***: It might be years down the road, but you know you did that project a couple years ago so we're going to tag you to pick back up on it and do the next the next round.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, you sure gonna benefit from having written those lessons learned and a nice concise document.
**Susan Daniels***: That you can read quickly and go oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah I remember that Okay, because our memories aren't everything we think they are.
**Susan Daniels***: And these lessons learned is like a letter than to write to yourself, saying this is how you can do it better next time.
**Susan Daniels***: And it's not just the things that went wrong but it's also the things that went very well like exceptionally well and then you want to be sure to do again next time now, if you are not the project manager in the future iteration.
**Susan Daniels***: These lesson learned documents get archived with your project and the person say it's susie.
**Susan Daniels***: goes looking for the archive of the previous project and opens up and finds this lessons learned letter.
**Susan Daniels***: Oh, my goodness, you have now set this new project manager on solid footing.
**Susan Daniels***: And they're going to remember you and how well, you did the lessons learned to help him or her, as well as the company succeed so lessons learned is sort of the difference between a project manager winging it and a project manager, who is a professional.
**Susan Daniels***: Lessons learned is an essential part of archiving your project you create it while you're doing your performance reporting hey things you're learning from your your.
**Susan Daniels***: Analysts analysis of your projects and their performance that you're getting in but you write it during your project, but you archive it at the end.
**Susan Daniels***: Now, in agile, they do it a different way they don't write the lessons learned okay are captured also along the way Okay, but the lessons learned are done in a group setting ceremony called a sprint retro sprint sprint retrospective.
**Susan Daniels***: This is when the team in real time dialogues with each other to go what went well what went what did not go well, what should we do differently.
**Susan Daniels***: And they try to incorporate their their lessons learned as quickly as possible into their ongoing project so that it continues to perform at a greater velocity.
**Susan Daniels***: Now you you realize when you're doing your lessons learned if you can fix it right away, you do right it goes on your issue log you resolve your issue I updated the distribution list for xyz report right issue solved right.
**Susan Daniels***: But that would also kind of go into your lessons learned right make sure you include this component of the company, because they care when you're doing this project.
**Susan Daniels***: yeah.
**Susan Daniels***: Sometimes you negotiate special intervals, and this has to do with agile, we talked about the go live dates or the blackouts for go live dates, but we also have um.
**Susan Daniels***: Special times when you don't want to do any arm.
**Susan Daniels***: You want to have downtime the best way to put it, and you want your team to be able to do those retrospectives right they're not available.
**Susan Daniels***: They have special intervals, that they are doing the retrospectives or they're doing on.
**Susan Daniels***: Release planning Okay, where they want to make sure that they're looking long range big picture.
**Susan Daniels***: And they are focused, so you have blackouts times when deliverables are handed over for implementation, and you are not doing any additional changes at that time Okay, this is very helpful when you're working with an external customer.
**Susan Daniels***: Then you've been working working working with them and now it's you believe the you've shown them the product right they've accepted the product and now you're putting it into go alive well.
**Susan Daniels***: While you're doing that you don't want them calling up going, but you need to change this, I don't like the font the way it looks on the screen.
**Susan Daniels***: And I want you to add another field on screen for because we didn't think about it before, and they want it like instantaneously you basically want to pre negotiate with your customer or we're going to.
**Susan Daniels***: Deliver and then we're going to give you a frequent looks up feedback for continuous improvement afterwards.
**Susan Daniels***: agile is very much about working in small increments and delivering value as quickly as possible we're constantly trying to deliver value to the company step back assess.
**Susan Daniels***: Get feedback adapt and go forward with the next deliverable like it great we keep going.
**Susan Daniels***: Like it no Okay, what do you need differently okay we'll put that in the backlog, do you need that right away, or do you need it, you know it can wait.
**Susan Daniels***: I can live with what I got, but I do want that change Okay, so you put it into the backlog the backlog is little more than a long list of things that the customer wants think is prioritized on a regular basis.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so we have a few questions here that are called mastery builder and you'll find this these from the knowledge check section on your low choice pmi website so we're going to take a moment, and what I would like, for you to do is, I would like, for you to arm.
**Susan Daniels***: read it, and then put what you think is the arm.
**Susan Daniels***: where's i'm just checking.
**Susan Daniels***: For.
**Susan Daniels***: So our lessons learned not incorporated in real time some can be some cannot be I mean you just blow it right there was something that happened, and you solved it but.
**Susan Daniels***: there's nothing once you solved it it's not like it's an ongoing continuous process improvement improvement, yes, solve the problem in life went on where.
**Susan Daniels***: Some of them like updating your distribution list can be a permanent real time and ongoing so your lessons learned captures all of that okay.
**Susan Daniels***: So for this question what are some techniques that a project manager can use to appraise the skills of potential team Member, which means, this is going back to the first hour we work together.
**Susan Daniels***: Please put in chat what you think the right answer is okay i'm beginning to see it okay ability test focus group from somebody I got A and B I got first to any way you want to put it okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Here we go now they're beginning to come through.
**Susan Daniels***: being engaged.
**Susan Daniels***: I am seeing quite a bit of consensus.
**Susan Daniels***: Another comment by Graham is that sometimes your fix is going to be different than next time then from the current problem, but you want to alert them that you had a problem in this space right that's another value of your lessons learn Okay, and people are responding looking good.
**Susan Daniels***: does seem to be quite a bit of consensus.
**Susan Daniels***: So let's go ahead and check.
**Susan Daniels***: it's the ability to test all kinds of different ability test right that are available to test them on we're seeing that becoming more common.
**Susan Daniels***: And i'm screenings now through these big job boards, but the focus group is also used by the project manager.
**Susan Daniels***: to appraise the skills, the skill set of a team Member if that's just not their area right if that's not something that you know how to do.
**Susan Daniels***: And you can't really evaluate, but you know you need the best you can get so you bring in a group of people to help you focus on identifying the strongest possible they bring in the different candidates and they help you.
**Susan Daniels***: Make the best selection so focus group is pretty similar to using a.
**Susan Daniels***: mini people not like a panel interview Okay, but you're the one setting up the panel.
**Susan Daniels***: And the panel will then be the focus group you're using to get the on the right job description, with the right skill sets you know articulating that for you and they may or may not be available to help you actually interview.
**Susan Daniels***: oftentimes you need at least one.
**Susan Daniels***: What does it mean if you are identified as an R in a racy chart.
**Susan Daniels***: The answers are coming through.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i'm seeing right answers.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: looking good.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: you're responsible for the activities execution.
**Susan Daniels***: Now there isn't one for your engaged there isn't like an engaged provide needed inputs.
**Susan Daniels***: engaged can be consulted engaged could be on.
**Susan Daniels***: accountable okay.
**Susan Daniels***: very clearly the right answer is, you are responsible for the activities execution, so this gives me a moment to talk to you about pmi questions.
**Susan Daniels***: They are often looking for the best answer okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Now, unless they tell you there is more to choose to you're only going to choose one, which means you're going to choose the best answer.
**Susan Daniels***: And although this is sort of directionally correct to say you should be engaged to provide needed inputs it isn't the best clearest answer which is you are there you go responsible for the activities execution.
**Susan Daniels***: they're not trying to be tricky they're just trying to get you to really look at each answer and Rule one in or out Okay, and when you come down to two okay you're looking for the best one.
**Susan Daniels***: Question when answering a multiple choice question on the plp exam if the answer expects to answers and you only choose one answer do you receive partial credit.
**Susan Daniels***: Actually, you do okay.
**Susan Daniels***: um, it has to do with whether you're highly proficient proficient or minimally proficient they look at your score So yes, you get partial credit, but you should at least guess okay.
**Susan Daniels***: They don't take points away for wrong answers, but you do lose points for not answering.
**Susan Daniels***: Which is the following our components of a resource calendar.
**Susan Daniels***: hey we've talked about each one of these right.
**Susan Daniels***: So the question then becomes are we talking about the resource management plan.
**Susan Daniels***: Are we talking about which would have your.
**Susan Daniels***: Recognition plans in it that's your resource management plan are we talk, you would also your resource management plan would also have your training strategies.
**Susan Daniels***: But only your resource calendar Now you can probably pick up the days here right because we're talking about the calendar itself very specific.
**Susan Daniels***: But when it comes to availability of physical resources that's the whole purpose of the calendar.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: it's very important to know what ties to what i've said this once on you're going to hear me say it repeatedly when you see checklist and it's tied to an item, you want to study those so you can match them back up.
**Susan Daniels***: Again project management that the test once you to look at all the answers and eliminate the ones that don't apply Okay, so we would roll out training and recognition, even though it has to do with resources it's not the resource calendar they apply to the resource management plan.
**Susan Daniels***: See if there's any questions relative to that.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: The question that floated by was will it always tell you how many to pick yes, it will tell you.
**Susan Daniels***: and want you to succeed they're not trying to play I gotcha Okay, but it's important that you read the care of the question carefully and look for the directions um oftentimes in our hurry.
**Susan Daniels***: People you know, trying to rush towards the end kind of glance at the question and that's kind of a fatal mistake.
**Susan Daniels***: Read the question very, very carefully.
**Susan Daniels***: Because only if you understand the question are you well positioned to pick the right answer you might bust through the the answers and then going I can I know that doesn't apply no that doesn't apply but.
**Susan Daniels***: And then you have to slow down to figure out what's the best answers and those that are left, but always read the question with great deliberateness okay slowly okay if you're on a particular role, this is where you slow down take a breath.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay Now I understand the ask and go through your answers okay so we're not reaching as much consensus in the answers here okay i'm getting a's and b's and a's and b's and a's and b's okay so i'm getting a lot of variety so i'm gonna let that keep running.
**Susan Daniels***: How many questions do you need to answer.
**Susan Daniels***: that's all in a video that's available to you on what to expect for the test title apply for the at home that the exam with the application and test taking taking techniques is available on your student folders on your different platforms, but the short answer um.
**Susan Daniels***: I i'm going to let.
**Susan Daniels***: The mentors put the right answer and for me i'm only thinking of 180 minutes and I know that's not the right answer for the number of questions, my apologies, so 200 Thank you appreciate that 200 questions in 180 minutes so let's go ahead and look at the right answer here.
**Susan Daniels***: 175 of them are graded 25 of them are them just testing test questions now you're not going to know that that one doesn't count.
**Susan Daniels***: Because they want you to take all of them seriously, but if it doesn't test well.
**Susan Daniels***: Then it isn't counted in future p&p exams, let me give you an example, have you ever read a quest.
**Susan Daniels***: test question and you still didn't understand the question, much less how to pick the right answer well that's a poorly written question Okay, I mean if you don't understand the question.
**Susan Daniels***: Now, how to decide what the right answer is that's where the you know the word might be but.
**Susan Daniels***: Sometimes they test questions get developed and they're just not well structured particularly they might not translate into another language well.
**Susan Daniels***: So they're they're taking a good maybe English question and it doesn't test well in Spanish, or it doesn't test well in Chinese so.
**Susan Daniels***: They will then go well, that one doesn't work and they want included so there's 200 questions hundred and 75 count and.
**Susan Daniels***: The nice thing is when you walk out of the test, if you have a couple questions you got I didn't get that you know, there was just a couple I can get just like I didn't get that.
**Susan Daniels***: don't feel that there might be one of those poorly composed test questions because you know you've studied, you know you've done your research, you know your your due diligence.
**Susan Daniels***: Sometimes they're just squirrely questions are bad questions Okay, in the last couple of minutes on so when it comes to the team charter okay.
**Susan Daniels***: emphasis here is on team your project objectives are going to be on your project charter okay your resource assignments, are going to be.
**Susan Daniels***: In your resource assignment matrix or it can be in your resource management plan okay.
**Susan Daniels***: But what we know goes in the team charter, because this is exactly how we're going to play well together right is what our shared values, about respect and honesty and punctuality right.
**Susan Daniels***: And how we're going to handle conflict kind of a step by step, guide and the statement that unresolved conflict will not.
**Susan Daniels***: be acceptable, you know conflicts will not go unresolved.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: look into the chat.
**Susan Daniels***: What is a passing score for the plp certification.
**Susan Daniels***: They will tell us there is not a number, but what we have learned by being trainers over the years.
**Susan Daniels***: Is that when you're able to pull mock test questions and you're able to get eight out of 10 of them correct rather consistently Okay, then you're ready okay.
**Susan Daniels***: And there are an array of test question providers, and there are some available through your training palm administrators platform so.
**Susan Daniels***: Just you kind of know when you're ready when you can go through these test questions and you recall the recognition, the reason why that's the right answer is clear to you so even if it's asked a little different.
**Susan Daniels***: You know why, if that's the right answer and why the other ones are wrong right so just getting more and more familiar with the content and practice.
**Susan Daniels***: But they won't tell you, you have to have you know 8590 7565 they won't tell you that it's not published it's a secret exactly okay um is it paper or digital okay well.
**Susan Daniels***: Your choice Okay, you can do a digital test which is what's provided at the testing centers or you can have a home and home test, you can test at home again there's more on that available through video.
**Susan Daniels***: On or, if you prefer, you can have a paper version it takes longer to grade, but you still it's a process is still available.
**Susan Daniels***: What do I suggest regarding digital or paper um all of my material is digital all of my training materials are digital i'm used to working digital, so I would be fairly comfortable working with digital um.
**Susan Daniels***: But that's a personal preference, if you are much more tactile and really like on the possession of that paper and to you know, maybe doodle are think you know through you're welcome to use paper.
**Susan Daniels***: Then the question becomes well what if I need to doodle digitally do it, I can I have paper what they have is a whiteboard you have you have access in the training online version to a digital whiteboard.
**Susan Daniels***: And it's advised that you start practicing how to use a digital whiteboard with your mouse or with a stylus if you have.
**Susan Daniels***: A digitized or pad or a touch screen my you fundamentally are not given paper.
**Susan Daniels***: When you do the at home online version, if you go to a testing Center sometimes they will give you a physical whiteboard and a.
**Susan Daniels***: marker and you can do your math problems there, or you can write down key terms after you've watched you know what after you started the test to be able to remember key terms right to help you kind of have a reference sheet.
**Susan Daniels***: So it's really up to you what your preferences digital at home digital in a testing Center or on paper.
**Susan Daniels***: At the location.
**Susan Daniels***: Someone saying the test perhaps have been helpful in principia great.
**Susan Daniels***: What do you recommend is digital platform for database for question answer to practice for the test.
**Susan Daniels***: On if you're coming into principia they have test test test prep questions if you're coming into another platform we're going to have to ask one of the mentors to respond what your test prep is, but I think i'm i'm new at this if you haven't caught on.
**Susan Daniels***: There is test question available, the different arm.
**Susan Daniels***: Online platforms and through different providers out there anybody, I recommend that would be kind of against going against the arm the skill soft i'm not really here to recommend other brands, you know just not in a position to do that.
**Susan Daniels***: Can you bring your own calculator that's a good question, the answer is you're not going to need one ones provided.
**Susan Daniels***: hey we can spend quite a bit of time talking about how to get ready for this test but we've reached the bottom of the hour, so i'm going to go ahead and put you guys on break, so we have a full hour for lunch.
**Susan Daniels***: And if we have additional time at the end of the next set of sessions, I will be glad to entertain questions regarding what to expect.
**Susan Daniels***: As we use that the balance of this time have a great lunch go ahead if you, you can Carl do you want them to sign off at lunch or can they stay signed on.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm not sure which is advisable.
**Susan Daniels***: Carl know stay signed on okay he's pretty clear okay stay signed on just have a nice lunch and i'll see you back at 230.